united's
against racism on the pitch statements
against racism have now become
commonplace
leeds and manchester united the latest
to take a knee this afternoon
but much of the abuse players suffer is
off the pitch and online
which is where the sport will now take
its protest with a four-day boycott of
social media
starting next friday enough is enough
you know players are planning matches
and
they're making mistakes and then they're
getting slaughtered that doesn't that's
not right for me
so the fact that we you know as a game
and the premier league
now said this enough's enough take them
off social media
and see what effect it has former
arsenal striker thierry henry was the
first to walk away from social media
last month
citing the toxic levels of abuse some
individual clubs have followed with
temporary boycotts of their own but next
weekend it'll be the entirety of english
football
switching off from facebook twitter and
instagram
this is where the power of football as
we've seen over the last week
when it does come together is enormously
powerful and
that one single message from the whole
is far greater than the sum of anything
that comes from the parts and on
individual clubs taking that action
when racist abuse is shouted from the
stands fans can be arrested
put in prison and given lifelong bans
but when it happens
online it can often go unpunished
users can remain anonymous by hiding
behind fake accounts which is why
football believes the social media
companies themselves
must do more to stamp it out the carabao
cup final at wembley today saw fans
return for the first time since the
pandemic began
and many here feel the problem of racism
should have been tackled much sooner i
don't know why it's been going on for so
long i know social media is a big thing
in
life nowadays but there's been so many
issues with it for so long
it's only a full day thing as well isn't
it it should be a lot longer boycotts a
big thing
and it kind of forces people to listen
even if they want to ignore it they
can't
facebook and twitter say they remove
harmful content when they see it
while instagram has introduced new
software to automatically filter abuse
but off the pitch it seems there's still
a long way to go before the beautiful
game
can live up to its name iva bennett sky
news
wembley